vas a una entrevista de trabajo y lo
primero que te dice la entrevistadora es
mira tienes una gran experiencia de
trabajo parece ser una persona joven y
agradable pero lo que realmente me
interesa son tus habilidades de
razonamiento lógico y lo que te dices
mira solo siéntate te voy a preguntar
algo sobre algunas expresiones
matemáticas y tú por supuesto dirás
adelante as me de estas preguntas soy
estudiante de lacan academy estoy seguro
de mí mismo
échame las y entonces te dice muy bien
tú tienes dos enteros
ahí ve digamos un entero hay un entero v
donde es mayor que cero es positivo y b
es menor que cero es decir es negativo
muy bien además te voy a dar otra
relación te dice que a / b va a ser
positiva va a ser más grande que a por b
muy bien entonces te te dice la
entrevistadora dime algunas cosas
interesantes de a bb b / b idea por be
ok entonces tú dices ok haré mi mejor
esfuerzo y aquí
el momento en donde yo te recomiendo que
hagas una pausa haz una pausa para que
pienses todas las relaciones posibles
que puedas encontrar de ave a / be up or
be ok piensa en todas las restricciones
que se imponen mutuamente con estas tres
o con estas tres afirmaciones ok
ok entonces suponiendo que ya existe una
pausa vamos a continuar digamos vamos a
vamos a tratar de analizar para quedar
muy bien con nuestra entrevistadora como
es a / b a es un número positivo y b es
un número negativo entonces si tú
divides a entre b tienes algo positivo
entre algo negativo
este número de aquí es negativo muy bien
qué pasa con a por b nuevamente este es
un número positivo y este uno negativo y
un positivo por un negativo nos da algo
negativo entonces ya tenemos algo dicho
ahí muy bien cómo se vería todo esto en
la recta numérica ok
digamos tenemos aquí nuestra recta
numérica digamos que por acá por aquí
han del 0 y entonces nuestra nuestra
relación que tenemos aquí nos dice que a
/ b es mayor que a por b quiere decir
que aprobé si ambos son negativos al
menos a por b debe ser mucho más
negativo entonces a entre de digamos si
éste es a entre b debe estar más cerca
del cero que lo que va a estar a por b
muy bien entonces esto mismo nos está
diciendo que el valor absoluto de a
entre b debe ser mucho más chico que a
por b donde el valor absoluto sabemos
que es la distancia al cero verdad de
cero
entre b hay una menor distancia que de
cero aa por b y entonces la
entrevistadora se ha quedado
impresionada y te dice oye ha dicho
mucho de muy poquita información de sólo
tres afirmaciones sin embargo yo quiero
un poquito más dame una restricción que
deba tener b entonces vamos a ponernos a
pensar sabemos qué
al menos el valor absoluto de a / b debe
ser más chico que el valor absoluto de a
por b sin embargo como que quizás de
aquí no sale mucho esta está quizás no
es tan claro cómo sacarla la restricción
sobre b así que vamos a trabajar sobre
esta de aquí vamos a trabajar sobre esta
de aquí y multiplicamos por ver de ambos
lados entonces tengo a / b y lo
multiplicamos por b y también del otro
lado tengo a por b y lo multiplicamos
por b
sin embargo acabamos de multiplicar por
b y b es un número negativo así que
cuando multiplicamos por un número
negativo la desigualdad se invierte se
cambia entonces ahora tenemos un menor
que ok vamos a continuar porque b / b se
cancelan y entonces me queda que a es
menor que a por b por b y eso es a por b
cuadrado muy bien ahora vamos a tratar
de cancelarla dividiendo entre a de
ambos lados sin embargo como a es
positivo pues
la desigualdad no hay nada más que
hacerlo así que la entrega se vuelve uno
a entregar se cancela y knox nos queda
que uno es menor que b cuadrada o lo que
es lo mismo que el valor absoluto de b
es mayor que uno y te dirá soy yo voy a
ver de dónde salió esto a bueno pues es
claro que si ve es más grande que uno el
cuadrado seguirá siendo más grande que
uno por ejemplo 2 al cuadrado es 4 3 al
cuadrado es 9 y así sucesivamente verdad
sin embargo también debe cumplir bueno
aquí tenemos que ver mayor que uno o
bien
también sabemos que puede ser menor que
menos 1 y es exactamente el mismo
argumento verdad si b es más chico que
menos 1 b cuadrada va a ser más grande
que uno por ejemplo si ves menos 2 pues
el cuadrado es menos 2 x menos 2 que es
4 positivo muy bien entonces estas dos
afirmaciones son equivalentes a que b
cuadrada sea mayor que 1 pero también
esto es equivalente a esto muy bien
entonces tenemos justamente ya la
restricción de b y entonces
hay que pensar todavía un último detalle
porque no estamos considerando que b es
negativo entonces si b es negativo pues
esta opción queda descartada y por lo
tanto lo único que sabemos es ahora que
b es más chico que menos 1 y entonces
después de todo este análisis tu
entrevistador estará muy impresionada y
seguramente dirá mira ha se ha hecho un
gran razonamiento aquí creo que mereces
el empleo